hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong my name is Mark
Ellis joined as always by my co-pilot
really the Han to my Chewbacca dare I
say the Leonardo to my Michelangelo
Jacqueline Coley here once again how you
doing yes because we can make Brian and
Remsen Donatello we definitely have a
lot of donatellos behind the scenes here
at Rotten Tomatoes no I agree so good to
see you again sir it's hot it's July
it's good to be seen it's very hot
outside I am uh scorching up the
YouTubes right now uh thanks to all
things comedy the special dropped last
week alive and well and you can check it
out if you've not already enjoyed my new
hour wherever you enjoy stand up
particularly youtubing just go to all
things comedy's Channel which brings us
to our guest today and our topic here
Eric Griffin comedian actor host of his
podcast riffin with Griffin also found
on the all things Comedy Network where
we're Network Bros yeah I'm the Rizzoli
to your aisles
the Franklin of my back
are we just gonna keep this only on TNT
you're lazy wow
but I feel like we have a great topic
and this is one that you know I I always
love talking about this movie because
this hearkens back to I'm sure all of
our childhoods but when you think back
about the movies that you got as a kid
you got excited to go see there was a
lot of animated Fair out there and then
live action crops up and you say oh okay
we had a live-action Batman live-action
Superman and then 1990 happened and the
dawn of a new decade brought us Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles 41 rotten on the
Tomato Meter 81 with the audience score
so that's the movie that we're going to
be asking folks is Rotten Tomatoes wrong
I want to give a shout out to our fan uh
Steve irwerman uh remember the fresh
ketchup crew who said I enjoy the
episode on Super Mario Brothers from
1993. in sticking with a cartoon video
game genre what about the live-action
TMNT from 1990 41 rotten which I think
is Criminal so I loved it as a kid still
holds up today keep up the good work we
also have mutant Mayhem the new Turtles
movie coming out August 2nd so there's a
lot of turtle buzz in the air and we
figured it's time to get down to brass
tacks and talk about this movie
which is not the highest rated Ninja
Turtles film do you know the highest
rated Ninja Turtles film is
animated or live action is the secret of
Zeus animated or live action it's got to
be the one with uh what's her face
I don't know April O'Neil no she's an
old no no no the one with Megan Fox
Megan Fox oh yeah no neither one of
those oh you have Batman versus the
Ninja Turtles it's an animated movie
from 2019 100 I don't know how many
credits reviewed but it's 100 on the
tomatoes that's a mashup anytime you get
a mashup you know that's it you can't
have Rizzoli Without Eyes
I think I think Alien vs Predator would
beg to differ on that one no that one
we're probably outside of a comedy club
talking about this weekend man it all
goes down yeah because because they that
was one of those ones that like it took
so long for them to make but they were
teasing it for like 20 years you had the
Dark Horse Comics in the 90s which are
really good and like we both loved the
individual franchises how can that miss
you know what it is is sometimes it's uh
this is a great you'll love this example
sometimes a movie has a great concept
but they they didn't follow through you
know what's a great example of that in
time with Justin Timberlake yeah okay
like that didn't think we talked about
that today but here we are saying that's
a great concept for a movie it is yeah
right it could actually be a great HBO
well not HBO Max show now or something
just Matt whatever it would be a great
show now you know or like like Silo on a
Apple TV it's like just a great like
little show but then they just didn't
you know yeah the log line was there
yeah but nothing else yeah I'll raise
you that Olivia Wilde movie that didn't
don't worry darling the directed Olivia
Wilde movie that's a great pitch okay
that I mean white women get out like
that's a pitch
yeah that's a pitch I buy it and I would
watch it and then it did not end up
being that it's really weird if you
pitched to anybody in in okay let's go
back to like the late 80s and say okay
hey my kids love playing with these
turtles that are toys and it's based on
comic books Kevin Eastman Peter Laird I
think I want to do a live action version
of this does the board laugh you out of
the room or do they say I don't know
maybe we can capitalize on this
you know are we going to talk about the
movie now we're getting well okay let me
let me ask you this because I have a lot
I have a lot of things to say I love
when a guest comes fully loaded ready to
go let me simply ask you this is Rotten
Tomatoes wrong about the 41 tomato man
they're very wrong because it should
have been way lower what the movie was
terrible oh my God
locked and loaded yeah this is this
Turtle slander but I will say this I
have the reason I think that I'm saying
that is because of like
our knowledge now it'd be like looking
at that one of those first Spider-Man
movies and I'm not talking about the
Tommy McGuire I'm talking about remember
when they tried to do Captain America
Spider-Man
you know what I mean
89. yeah yeah yeah you know you could
see the you know you know what I mean
it's like that's what was up with this
movie you saw so it was hard to like
take off the prism of uh we know now
what we know now and when you watch that
like to me like that that movie should
have could have been called like you
know Teenage Ninja Turtles you know
Electric Boogaloo you know what I mean
if it was a musical it would have been
better you know what I mean like if they
would all of a sudden started to go down
it's arguably the best MC Hammer
soundtrack in movies
family which is also great but uh at the
end of time it might be a better movie
Jacqueline but MC Hammer came to play
did the turtles is Rotten Tomatoes wrong
it's so interesting interesting too
because it goes from MC Hammer to
Vanilla Ice in the next one it's like
really what do we do no I do think the
music definitely hit hard on this this
was so weird like looking back on like
this movie just how it opens it is so
built in the like scare white people
about New York 80s like it was so set in
that like it's like a bad play you know
what I mean before Giuliani got there I
mean it was just so weird and what we've
come to learn now is like so much of
that was because of these movies it
wasn't really based on reality that
there was this like huge there was
definitely a crime influx in the 80s but
it wasn't you would have thought that
you can't walk down the streets in New
York without being stabbed it terrified
me as a kid see this movie yeah we had
gotten out of the Air Force so we were
in Virginia when I saw this movie but
yeah like going to New York like the
opening of this movie is just a bunch of
kids pickpocketing back and forth and it
turns out they're members of the Foot
Clan but the movie itself are you happy
with 41 I would say the 41 is an
accurate reflection of how bad this
movie is at times but I had so so much
fun way that I can't really call it a 41
movie and it's still it's a it's a movie
what was weird with it is this backflip
in a time when kids movies could be dark
I mean this is before I think even
Kindergarten Cop right like Kindergarten
Cop was around the same time I think
Kevin might have gotten there first but
might have gotten there first so this
was still around the time where they
would still hide like kids movies with
this like I mean look secret of the Nim
that thing should have been R-rated you
know what I mean
Return to Oz this was a part of that
time frame where they wanted to scare
kids before they then talk about Oz on
HBO No Return to Oz
like you're trying to see like a movie
that's nudity but then Oz comes on it's
like I want no part of whatever oh my
God anyway so I would say that if for
what it is the 41 is accurate but I just
don't think it's a reflection of what
the movie intends could be and who it's
for who it's for it's an easy 60. I
would put it in there yeah Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong this is a fresh movie
this is a fresh movie adult or child
either this is you can have a ball watch
in this everybody comes to play it's one
of those great villain great Heroes
great sidekick with Casey Jones and
April O'Neil A Little Bit of Love Story
there's some interesting it's a bad
version of big Big Trouble in Little
China
I'll take a bad version of big trouble
little China
didn't know what it was this movie is
just another like you know Camp mad cap
Adventure type movie
how dare you listen it like that whole
like little China dark underworld like
it's the same thing with Total Recall
all of y'all are doing Theater Camp with
sci-fi costumes I'm so sorry you know
what I mean just I I love what Elias
coteus is doing this yeah Rotten
Tomatoes is definitely wrong but I I
want to say this I cannot call this a
good movie The cinematography the acting
the set choices the plotting it is a
trauma Style movie but I dare you to
tell me that I didn't live for Toxic
Avenger I got some good stylistic
choices of this film made but we'll talk
about that movie talk right now
Jacqueline it is your duty to tell us
what this movie's about what's the
synopsis of teenagers I mean have you
watched an episode of Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles because it's pretty much
the same one I've been in the 80s of the
1980 these and basically we are trying
to find out what is happening in the
dark underworld of New York City we have
investigative reporter April O'Neal Who
Intrepid who is on the like back when we
believed news reporters could actually
discover something investigative
journalists she is sort of venturing
Into the Dark World and she gets rescued
from the Foot Clan by these sort of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles that are
living we're not sort of yes not sort of
well they are not actually that's just
the name we call them they don't call
themselves Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
they just call themselves Turtle freaks
kicking ass which they are which they
are yeah she gets rescued by them meets
all of these various characters the Foot
Clan which is Head Up by Shredder we
have their master who was radioactively
made just like the rest of them there
was an experiment the Ooze it turns them
into the Turtles Master Splinter who is
a rat trains them in the way of
Taekwondo they all have various weapons
they are led by Leonardo and between
them with April O'Neil they try to bring
down Master Shredder along the way we
also meet Casey Jones played by Alaska
who gave us what I would like to call
line cook energy before we all
understood what that meant
this man walked so that Jeremy Ellen
White and the bear could run ladies and
gentlemen the same energy he just has
much better Taekwondo skills
mad cat Adventures ensue there are nerds
listening right now that are just like
I'll keep going
you know what I mean get deeper into
this this is like a nerd 976 number
do you want me to tell you about the
Ninja Turtles baby
it's like can you tell me a little bit
about Transformers 2007 please yeah
well you know what I I could continue
but honestly that's the best ending of
that synopsis that I will ever get it
goes downhill from here watch the movie
yeah it's based on the animated series
and the comic books before that and you
basically have the good guys or the
turtles the bad guys are Shredder in the
Foot Clan okay and uh there's other
people I didn't even get into like the
other various characters but like I said
thank you for that I'm too embarrassed
like the cheeks are red ladies and
gentlemen and I am a black woman I'm
gonna stop
that's why the Nerds are like on it
they're enjoying it um here's the thing
though all right here's let me put some
context to where I feel this movie was
you know terrible all right wait wait
wait wait hold on hold on because you
gotta be critics yeah all the critics I
wanna hear from the credit these are
critics in 1990 when this movie came out
we're gonna hear from the critics for
our segment two minutes with Tim Tim
Ryan
take it away
[Music]
at this point the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles are a pop culture institution
beloved by several generations of
children including my eight-year-old and
his friends so it's easy to forget that
at the time when the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles movie was released in 1990
there was more than a little concern
about the turtle's influence on kids the
criticism came down to two main issues
the level of violence in the video games
and TV series and the utter ubiquity of
the turtles is pitch Bend for products
directed at children and let's face it
there's not nothing to that the turtles
did get in lots of fights and they were
in a lot of commercials of course kids
were substantially less concerned about
that stuff than either their parents or
newspaper pundits but it does partially
explain why a lot of grown-up film
critics were less than enthused about
the movie Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
is rotten at 41 on the Tomato Meter with
54 reviews and it has an 81 percent
audience score an FYI rotten it may be
but it's the best reviewed Ninja Turtles
theatrical release to date
so what did the critics have to say in a
rotten review Gene Cisco of the Chicago
Tribune wrote the cynicism of the motion
picture industry will be apparent to any
child who is exposed to the many product
plugs for a nationwide pizza delivery
company
however in a fresh review Richard
Harrington The Washington Post wrote
truth be told there's something
amusingly surreal in watching these
happy-go-lucky man-sized Terps engage in
full-scale punch and kick outs with the
inevitable villains the Rotten Tomatoes
critics consensus reads Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles is exactly as advertised
one-liners brawls and general silliness
good for the young at heart irritating
for everyone else
so that's Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Cowabunga thank you Tim that was a great
recap of how people were feeling in 1990
when the turtles were a new phenomenon
in full disclosure before this show I
wanted to do some sort of wardrobe nod
to the Turtles um I put this on this was
not my shirt and wardrobe but this looks
like a shirt that any 10 year old would
wear so I wore a 10 year old kid shirt
for the show today
Barbie and that's from 1990. your shirt
oh frying trading since 1990. oh look at
that it sets it I mean this is this was
destined to happen let's get into the
movie talk hit the music Brian
[Music]
all right so it feels like Eric has a
lot of criticisms built up about this
movie before we get to your notes
uh what were you doing in 1990.
I was graduating from high school were
you already like oh the turtles are for
kids I'm an adult now I was never into
the turtles that was you know I was a
he-man Voltron Thundercats there you go
Robotech that was my thing yeah every
every kid has their drop-off Point mine
were Mighty Morphin Power Rangers so the
turtles were like the last of like the
new sort of phenomenon in a toy that I
like I would hang out like play with and
then then the Power Rangers came out and
I was like I think it's time to become
an adult no I was definitely a Power
Ranger kid I was actually past that
because I want to say
were you a turtle kid though I was a
turtle kid but it's weird because girls
are different because we had like brats
and you had Barbie yeah I'd Barbie
longer than I should have did your
Barbies ever make out with the Ninja
Turtles no they made out with Ken's and
GI Joes that's fair I was about to say
yeah I was also a GI Joe person yeah oh
yeah but then you know they took GI Joe
off the air because it was just a big
commercial for
no just for no it was a commercial for
selling products yeah and there's a law
about that oh really GI Joe just off the
air because of that you're hitting there
we get some uh maybe I didn't know
there's a rule about how much you can
sell to kids on air and I think it's
like a timing issue like the reruns of
GI Joe is probably the issue oh wow it
was just it was just that the whole
cartoon was just an advertising
advertisement oh wow I just remember
what like watching the turtles on on the
animated show which is how I came to
them and my my little brother was like
like obsessed with eternal so that's
kind of how I got into them but like I
just remember watching their lifestyle
and thinking like that's awesome like if
you forget that they're living in a
literal sewer for a minute they did the
most they could do with their sort of
bachelor pad underground that they had
this Subterranean living quarters they
got to eat pizza all the time they put a
bunch of ridiculous toppings on Pizza
which I tried myself and that it was
really the pizza probably
dude I I love the turtles and I was like
that they're cool they're fun
Michelangelo's a party dude
um and so I Leonardo was my favorite
because he was kind of like the leader
you know but I was rooting for all of
them with the possible exception to
Raphael who I think is a cancer he's a
locker room cancer wow and he and he
literally is the reason why we're going
through all the steps in this movie is
because he made a rash decision on his
own instead of working inside the
infrastructure of the team I couldn't
tell you who was who Raphael is the one
that has the size it wasn't my he's got
the like you know the thingies that look
like this like yeah he's got the size
he's basically Antonio Brown like he'll
play with you for a little bit and then
just completely goes off the rails okay
I disagree because when we were doing
this I don't know whose episode where I
broke down like the mythology behind
each of the turtles and why they have
their weapons yeah right you do you
can't just have blind soldiers you do
need the one person who is going to be
the naysayer in any group because one's
out of every 10 times that's the person
that knows no that's some like it's
right you know what I mean like you
can't just have everyone be like that's
why they were a cohesive group yeah like
they balance each other out express
himself but at some point you got to
realize we have to stop the shredder and
the Foot Clan before I get my little
proclivities yeah
if Leonardo's coming up with a band
Master Splinter coming up with a plan
and basically by your logic you know why
am I on an island here you should be on
an island because nobody is nobody is
above somebody at least
testing the tensile strength I think
it's great to have somebody like Raphael
in your group because you know as a
leader if you're gonna bring something
you have to get it past this guy because
he's not just gonna just be the person
like everyone else like Michelangelo to
go with it all right you need that
locker room guys sometimes dude you're
selling me on that a little bit but
Raphael puts the teenage in Teenage
Mutant Ninja and he's doing exactly what
he should for his age he's the one
that's like really struggling with
puberty to keep up with the other kids
all right so but they all form a team
and and I think Master Splinter is is
marvelous in this movie as the as the
Yoda the Mr Miyagi if you will and I
love that there's a backstory between
Splinter and orokosaki who turns into
Shredder where they have this like oh
wait we knew each other back in Japan
when I was a rat practicing my ninja
moves in a cage because that's what rats
do and then he gets abuted in on him and
he becomes this like kind of humanoid
rat thing and he can kind of go Toe to
Toe with shredder as far as like the the
mental wits go but then you need your
turtles to defeat Shredder's Army and
then Shredder including Tatsu who's a
great number two yeah um so there's a
lot stacked against the turtle boys what
I'll tell you one of my favorite scenes
of this movie then you guys can can kill
the bits if you want I love the scene
when we meet Shredder for the first time
because it's like all the Foot Clan is
like this underground like kind of Fight
Club looking thing and incidentally that
was the that was the same set that they
used for Super Mario Brothers Manhattans
of course the introduction of the
Shredder is so scary he walks in and
it's like he's doing an HBO stand-up
special in like 2001. like just this
really cool hyper stylized futuristic
looking place and he just gives them
this pep talk for the ages and like
they're ready to run through a brick
wall for this guy so that's why I love
Ninja Turtles and Casey Jones kicks a
lot of ass I was gonna say that's gonna
be my scene but who's your what's your
favorite moment from it do you have a
favorite moment do you have a moment
that you didn't like hate it no it just
it's not a good movie okay it's hard for
me to watch this movie because
again context I was trying to give
before is this is 1990. Jurassic Park
came out in 93 yeah 93 I'm saying but
that's around the arrow they were
working on so you didn't think that like
like the vision was fully realized until
JP hit yeah I mean this is like
yeah okay but I'm trying not to look at
it in the sense of like what we look at
now but this was like Sesame Street
but this is what's so funny when you see
it it's a fine line I'll give you that
this is like Sesame Street and you're
like oh hey buddy
how are you doing oh you know it was
just like really bad and I couldn't get
past it I tried to watch it because it
was coming on this I tried I was like
nah I can't do this and acting so bad
like it doesn't hold up
Jim Henson's company did that did the
costumes and stuff so there's some
Muppet Sesame Street connectivity there
you go between the look yeah but then
when they got rid of Jim Henson it was
awful so like I hate to say that because
I like this one because there's a story
about that if you've seen the other ones
where they have the mouths moving they
don't even match at least with this one
there's like real animatronic people
trying to make it as realistic as
possible I think I know that our eye
it's literally for those listening I'm
pulling down his eyes
I always think of the this is when the
world changed the world changed when
that dinosaur came on the screen okay
and everything before it that was trying
to be anything like that cease to see it
ceased to like exist it's just like it's
like nope right like I can't I saw
Jurassic Park in the theater nine times
yeah it was a it was a formative
experience that moment of that you know
when everybody's looking and you're just
like what you know so now you I can't
unknow
what I know yeah yeah so when those
Turtles came out I was like I'm good
you know what I mean I'm good I'm out
I'm out wow you know what I mean because
all I saw was like you know I couldn't
get past like all in my mind I saw I was
like okay cut and then it was like you
know a dude going
around got a cigarette we're going again
when are we going again are we going
again it's not even his voice because
they just you know it's just a dude like
some like grip yeah but there was no
attraction to the personalities of the
turtles either
I'm trying to tell you I wasn't a turtle
guy you know like I said like I
collected Comics so you know I was into
like you know Marvel and DC stuff and
you know like I say Thundercats He-Man
uh Robotech GI Joe that was my thing uh
you know this was like I'm like what
they're Turtles you know I just it just
it didn't grab me because I was at a
certain age where I was like this isn't
what you're looking at anymore no except
for kids you know what I mean it's also
like the age that you saw it probably
did you watch it in the theater
um I don't even remember I doubt that I
did because I wasn't into yeah I did I
was 10 and my brother was eight and my
mom took us and we lost our goddamn
Minds because but but here's the thing
though and it's interesting you bring up
like when we were growing up in the 90s
like you because back then the comic
books and the other sort of media you
had like the animated shows and even you
just playing with your toys that could
take a story so much further than what
was capable on screen right into the
Jurassic Park thing all right imagine
right so I think for me and again having
10 year old eyes on it helps and the
fact that I just discovered movie
theater nachos the previous year thanks
to Batman
um eating nachos and then knowing I'm
gonna get pizza right after this because
the turtle's eating pizza and then also
seeing them on screen in live action I
think was the closest thing to what we
would eventually get with Jurassic Park
up to that point and so I think that's
why I was like this feels real to me
because it's the closest to reality that
you could have something like that look
back in 1909 well when you're young and
like that's a very important note there
right like you know like because I'll
tell you my uh most
influential Movie experience okay like
my mom comes to me says we're going to
the movies right okay and I'm like I
don't wanna she goes we're gonna go see
Indiana Jones and I'm in I'm like what
I'll never forget this I'm like I'm just
pouting I'm so upset I imagine like like
little baby Eric but he's still got the
Gray beard and the hat
are you kidding I'm like are you kidding
me I'm sorry that image is just gonna
give nightmare fuel I don't mean to be
mad about this but just imagine a like
50 year old man with like the beard
little baby Herman oh you like that's
exactly what I was thinking of from
freaking um
I didn't want to see this crap yeah I
didn't know who Harrison Ford was just
like this is a nightmare I'm with my mom
and her friend embarrassing you know
it's embarrassing and they want to go
for Harrison Ford because he's pretty
exactly it was that kind of thing what
if my friends I gotta tell you when when
I left that thing I wanted a hat a whip
a leather jacket and I was running
around my house
and then for a long time when I was in a
a plane taking
um I would be looking out the window and
that that music would be in my head oh
yeah the map it went like like you're on
you're on a world atlas with the the red
dots so what I'm saying is like that was
my so when I you know so why I see the
turtles I'm like that's not Harrison
Ford and then you know but it is for
little kids no no I get them but I'm
just telling you my little kid
experience so it's like I have two movie
experiences that I that that one and
then my mom took me to see Return of the
Jedi yeah I don't even remember seeing
Star Wars and Empire Strikes Back but
Return of the Jedi was the first time
THX sound was uh that's the first time
so we're all in the theater and it's
like
oh my God you know then especially the
beginning of that movie where you hear
Darth Vader breathing in Ceramics and
then like so again when you watch the um
the the animal not the animation but
like you know the the production of Star
Wars yeah production of Indiana Jones
and then I see this crap there's no way
to follow it is what you're saying yeah
I'm sorry it's just like you know it's
like you're looking at them you're like
that's a suit I mean and I was at an age
where
that's a suit
you know what I'm saying this is are we
at Disneyland I yeah you know what I
mean yeah you go like I wonder who's in
the Mickey suit that's that's what it
was did the students bother you as a kid
when you saw it but I get what you're
saying about the suspension of disbelief
and I do believe when movies hit you at
a certain age your ability to suspend
disbelief is less I have a feeling after
this
you know what you're dealing with right
now if you're like on the if like I feel
like everybody has
different points in your life where you
can see things differently yeah like you
can see things differently if you're uh
had kids like you can see it through
your kids eyes you can see things
differently if you've been in a love and
had your heart broken the next time you
go see a rom-com that stuff hits harder
I think a 20 something year old dude
this movie is just not gonna hit you in
a good place yeah well what was it night
it was 1990 yeah so I was like 17 years
I'm playing you're already yeah
this was not gonna be mine it makes I'm
like I'm like you just seem like you
could suspend disbelief about some
things but I think they hit you at the
wrong you were you were me when when the
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers came on the
scene because to me that show and then
like the movie and like all that other
stuff it just it looked so corny and
people in tights like Barnyard play kind
of you know Lizzie McGuire that was when
I first realized I had aged out of
Disney by the way the thing I was into
way too late was Sailor Moon oh really
okay yeah because I was really
interesting go to Comic Con so you're
gonna see a lot of people in the Sailor
Moon I mean but it was like Sailor Moon
back when it was like playing cards and
you like bought Sailor Moon like sort of
like Kabuki stuff because I was like the
only stuff we could get here so I like
had all this Sailor Moon merch shout out
to my friend Annabelle who turned me on
to Sailor Moon in summer school there
you go you know it's like I I often
wonder like it must be so much harder
for
people to suspend their disbelief now
because they're spoiled no no no it's
because we are also more aware of things
now like when like I'll tell you uh like
Superman DC
when they when they when they started to
have this thing where like Superman had
a trial and they were like
um you like destroyed the city bro you
know what I mean like can we talk about
all this destruction that like that now
it's like now when I watch like
a fast and furious movie and the
inevitable gas truck is on the freeway
which I don't know why gas truck is
always driving on the freeway during
that is is that where you're is that
where you're heading your heart go yeah
is to that poor driver yeah yeah yeah
because that blows up so now I started
doing like this I'm counting doing a
Chase I go dead dead this dude's dead
yeah so now the random people too so now
in my mind I go like in this last Batman
with Robert Patterson you know he goes
and chases the penguin they they blew up
a freeway
how is the Penguin just walking away
from that the cost of human life you
just go now we go oh I can't just
suspend my disbelief because you've
introduced this into our world it's like
now when you're watching Marvel movies
and it's like a Thor movie and Aliens
are coming you're in your mind like
where's Iron Man
[Laughter]
[Music]
Iron Man look at the TV like oh you got
it Thor no it's just it don't work like
that anymore you have introduced a
reality into this thing now recliner
watching watching KTLA like I think
Thor's got this yeah yeah
I'm tired pepper don't even bother with
the suit stores got this so what I'm
saying is like it's like so that's the
kind of thing where you go you know back
then it didn't matter like there is a
sort of like numbness to violence and
things like that that people have before
but the more like realistic people you
want to get it's like I want us to spend
my disbelief okay it's like when I go
see John Wick I love John Wick okay yeah
and I I could I believe John Wick can
kill 400 people in in you know he's he
kills about a hundred or so people of
movies good stats okay it's ridiculous
I'm fine with that
but when he falls from a two-story
building oh yeah
and lands on a car I'm out
okay can he beat up 10 ninjas yes okay
can he hit every shot with his gun I
believe it but I don't believe him
falling from a two-story building and
landing on the roof of a car and then
getting off of it like this just shaking
off some glass just shaking off some
glass so what I'm saying is like all
right so you look at the prism of a
child looking at that movie because like
you know when you take a little kid to
Disneyland and and the Mickey Mouse
character comes over there what's in
their head they're just like oh my God
it's Mickey they lose their mind use
their minds but as an adult you're just
looking at this poor idiot you know it
kills it for me hot ass suit when I meet
Mickey or wait when I was a kid and I
met Mickey what killed the whole thing
for me was I was so excited to like Meet
Mickey and I think I shook Mickey's hand
and to feel that it was just like an
adult hand in there I was like this is
not Mick like what the hell who's who's
stolen oh yeah
but the thing is you can't unknow that
no no no no
now your mind unravels yeah and it's
like the curtain you know you see that
you're looking for The Wizard of Oz and
you're like oh no maybe I'm just
gullible I believe it all I okay so
here's the thing with the turtles though
and the thing to like like people
getting injured and like watching a fast
and furious movie I remember seeing a
Need for Speed a few years ago and
there's like a thousand cops that die in
that movie and all they're doing is
their job chasing after these guys that
are speeding and like all the cops are
dead so but with Ninja Turtles I think
because I saw that movie when I was 10
years old and as we know 10 year olds
are pretty able to well you can heal
from anything when you get injured as a
tank you can jump off the couch you can
jump off a bunk bed you can do whatever
you can wrestle with your brother in the
backyard you're never going to be
seriously injured it feels like don't
try this at home kids and then you have
that first injury
I don't remember any of that stuff that
Tim was talking about with like the
parents being concerned about the
violence in Ninja Turtles I don't
remember that the worst influence I
think the Ninja Turtles had on the Youth
of America was that you can you can like
be in shape and do martial arts and eat
nothing but Pizza they never saw a a
vegetable never saw the inside of those
Turtles bodies they also have shells so
like are we really trying to figure this
out like the shelves alone makes them
like they have they have pecs and they
have absolutely fat they can't get the
oh my gosh I do remember that and the
reason why I remember that was because
of the sequel oh my God y'all no the
sequel has great pizza no but the pizza
has a great sequel in it but it's also
less it doesn't go as hard as the first
one and that was a direct correlation to
the first one being such a hard PG-13
because it is still PG-13 even though
it's like a hard you see blood at the
end of it because they they basically
they they they punch Shredder off a
building into a garbage disposal thing
and Casey Jones hits the button to like
Shred the shredder and so then you see
all this Blood yeah and you're like whoa
this guy really went through some stuff
and it was a little like Temple of Doom
where it's like I didn't know that we
could get that violent with a movie like
this yeah I just wanted to mention this
because you mentioned about favorite
scenes is that you mentioned the
Splinter sort of intro but Shredder also
has an incredible intro and no I was
talking about the shredders sorry um but
also um uh Casey Jones also has a great
Instagram doesn't say I think all of the
characters to a certain degree and even
Splinter when you first encounter him in
the in the in the sewer like the way
they come into him and how he sort of
like gathers them all together after you
just witness them yeah all do this
badassery the fact that they all get in
line with the Splinter I think is also a
good thing I just want to say I think
the movie gets character introductions
right because it's the Wild Bunch you
have to make sure it's like the
Magnificent Seven you got to make sure
every single character that's why
Raphael is able to do his stupid stuff
you know I get it he's necessary I will
say this about the movie
um it doesn't showcase Turtle Health
Care in the best of lights because Raph
gets into a fight with a bunch of Foot
Clan because again he's a rogue now and
he's on his own and he gets killed with
he gets pummeled within like an inch of
his life so the turtle's plan to save
rap isn't like let's just expose
ourselves and take him to a hospital
they take him to some place in like
Upstate New York and it's just like a
whole house and their plan to
rehabilitate Raphael is they dump him in
a bathtub and hoping he wakes up yeah so
half the movie is just a dead journal in
the tub and they're in the other room
like playing board games and like
practicing martial arts yeah and then
eventually Raphael thank God wakes back
up would have been really awkward if he
just kicked it right there the movie I
want to see is like you know
it's like it opens up in New York and
it's like I like this narration and then
it's like you know yeah you know
interior okay
it's the turtles like you know they're
48.
you already told me it is very it's very
much like John Wick yeah people coming
you guys back in it this is Jesus guy I
can't even get into my call me at
dominoes and I'll think about it I can't
even get it to my shell like they open
up a closet you know and then his wife
is like are you good you better have me
put that video
can you find my super shell yeah it's
like Incredibles exactly
so then it's like you know them like
trying to like do it again that's the
movie you want to see is the is that
what mutant Mayhem is going to be it's
gonna be them in their Middle Ages yeah
I'm just trying to hold down a job yeah
cause I'm trying to get works so you're
probably not excited for this one no no
I'm not I'm not yeah I think the
animation looks like I don't like stuff
that looks like like super artistic is
that that we're supposed like that's
gonna last about two minutes we're gonna
be like oh then it's gonna be like uh
what is this I mean I would say I just
feel it look either his writers or his
producers or whatever I think Seth Rogen
at least usually knows how to make a
comedy vehicle that is somewhat
enjoyable well yeah that what was the
one the hot dog one uh yeah uh sausage
party sausage party which is to me was
something didn't mean to cut you off but
just to me me sausage party was like a
bunch of him and his friends
smoking weed lots of it lots of it and
somebody said what if we made a movie no
they had like a hot dog right here it
was like I think this is that sausage
talked and then they were like I bet you
I could make that movie it was like
Trading Places I bet you a dollar I bet
you a dollar I can make this movie and
make it a hit and they're like oh yeah
you know he was like okay and the
country was there at the premiere like
yeah right we all got the new voices I
can't believe we made this movie
that got produced by like Happy Madison
and anything about SNL like all of that
stuff it's just but that one was so yeah
ridiculous I'm just saying I think
comedians getting stoned saying let's
make a movie is half of this well they
don't get half of Hollywood
as much as you used to which is why I
was happy to see you know our buddies
Bert Kreischer and Sebastian Maniscalco
both had I just wish they would have
movies come out that uh I mean look for
comic's sake top five I think machine
like they're within like a hundred
thousand dollars of each other opening
weekend but they did around like five
six million and which is still like an
accomplishment because you're not
putting like those movies don't have the
budget they used to so you better look
at the budgets of those movies
the machine was the machine was like 30
40. yeah that's how we make our money
back gotta hope for it if you think
about it being a movie star is tough
yeah I mean Jennifer Lawrence is a legit
movie star I hope you can't open it I
don't know how that movie's doing I
don't know how sexy that screen does you
don't know this about me and this is not
this belies what happened earlier but I
am like the resident person around here
if it's smut on screen I'm the editor
that they always like let's get Jaclyn's
take on it like there's the Comic Book
Guy there's the sports guy and then
there's me of like is it dirty on screen
she will tell us whether this is actual
smut or something that has an audience
and that was really disappointing to me
that a sex comedy could not do well
because of puritanical youth like I am
upset about this this is where I'm gonna
get into my like comedian being like
we've gone too far
I think she was like good for her to be
like you know I wanted to do this I want
to do this I'm sure she's still
good-looking
and then it should I think they should
show them when they feel but listen
Jennifer Lawrence you're right she did a
sex comedy and it sucks that like now
that's going to be a cautionary tale for
anybody else trying to do one well I
mean I think it's I mean it's the the
jury is still out you know this is going
to be hopefully this is the door opening
back up so I appreciate her doing that
just the fact because Roger's got green
lips wanted to do it the Stars doing it
so they're doing so now maybe
Hollywood's gonna go let's see how's it
doing what's the landscape right now
because with the cancel culture and this
like all this stuff because it's all
fake it's not real like let me tell you
it's not real all right and the
companies that say have a checkered past
they're over correcting the most yeah
and and like in our minds we're looking
at this and we're like dude if I can
feel the diversity meeting when I'm
watching your movie
so it's like you're driving on the
freeway and like you you go off the lane
like one way and then you over correct
yeah and now I'm in the other lane they
always teach you like traffic's coming
you know yeah I'm here for this sexual
over correction I want to see like I was
just like everywhere Terminator
Terminator two in the middle Terminator
2 do you remember this they like Granite
it's a part of the plot that like John
Connor has to happen but they don't
gloss over that we get a full on Sarah
Connor re sexy that was the first one
then the first one 84. you know what I
mean like they always have an excuse for
that I like that last night we got a
handshake as the romantic moment in the
movie that we shot yeah right it was a
handshake fist bump yeah come on yeah
but but I will say I'm not a fan of
gratuitous nudity either no it's not
about that but but it's like to me it's
just like with the people dying it has
to make sense
service the story you know like I have a
bit about this that I talk about it's
like I because you know what I can't
stand is uh when I see a bra in a love
scene
[Music]
it's unprofessional
okay this should be out it's a love
scene you know why it's because that's
not a realistic moment nobody has sex
like that married people
nobody has their bra nobody has their
reports
by the way but I always say at the end
of that is like it's not for the nudity
it's not about me being a pervert it's
Artistic integrity but listen I don't
actually need to see this right you just
you still want to see a bra strap I just
need to believe yeah yeah
yeah so I I am when you're a kid
are you are you are you getting this
back to Ninja Turtles yes when you're a
kid none of this matters when you're a
kid it's just like oh yeah right that
Turtle suit looks like trash but it's
fine it's fine it's fine because the
turtle's boobs are out the Turtles out
the turtles aren't whatever you're into
they're not wearing any clothes yeah
this should be your favorite movie the
turtle's not wearing clothes when you're
10 you're not like Dad Mom the turtle
where's his yeah PP and it's like you
know think about that that is a good
question that I you know what I mean you
know yeah you just I was having too much
fun I don't want to forget this let's
not forget who Donatello is in this
movie uh-oh Corey Feldman Corey Feldman
the one by Corey Feldman oh fun pizza
fact before we're out of here so Pizza
Hut had a 20 million dollar campaign
with Ninja Turtles yeah they did but
it's hilarious with this movie because
the pizza featured in the movie is
Domino's yeah so they didn't get in the
movie but they had the marketing around
it well and it was everywhere I we went
to Pizza Hut we bought the uh the
cassette tape coming out of our shell
because that was when you would go to
Pizza Hut as a restaurant it was
restaurant pizza with the salad bar and
let me tell you how great you guys grow
up here's how great the Ninja Turtle
costumes were okay the ninja turtle in
the movie were so good that I remember
my mom told us like she saw a TV Guide
that the Ninja Turtle is going to be on
Oprah today
my brother and I are so excited and she
introduced here comes the turtles and
the turtles walk out and it was
different costumes that were not half as
good as the movies they had like liver
spots and stuff on them and that was
half as good it was bad and my brother
is this this is Ninja Turtles
placard with it said Turtle across the
front and oh we were so mad and ever
since then they don't trust black women
right
a smiling woman in a video that goes
viral on Tick Tock I have some questions
let's go to our big clothes Brian
[Music]
love all people
I love everyone I wasn't even mad at
Oprah I was mad at the turtles I'm not
saying Oprah was that Stephanie might
have something to do with it but not
Oprah look at this song look at it I'm
just gonna smile so when this goes viral
it's just me sitting here uh EG you're
always welcome on the show you're a
hilarious comedian a talented actor who
will get naked if the role was right if
the partner requires to see that that's
why it'll happen it's real it's really
real quick
first season of Workaholics there was
I'm reading the script and there is a
thing Montez walks out of the bathroom
naked and I looked at that I said wait
hold on a second let me I mean I really
want to say to this you act like
Workaholics was this this was it
we want to make a movie about the
about office like it's all like every
comedy show ever made is just comedians
a lot of it is exhale they're not making
it so did you have to be naked that's
true for my for that for that yeah yeah
but they just I had a thing on it yeah
the whole point was like the rule of D's
is that what like people stopping on the
street are they like is Montez usually
the what they what they see actually
nowadays because of social media it's
it's it's probably 50 50. that's good
what's the other well just social media
in general yeah they'll say oh Eric
Griffin yeah somebody else will be like
well it is you know but I mean are they
listening to the podcast is what I'm
saying I just think that when you want
to if you're a fan of a thing and you're
gonna go look for it yeah you're gonna
it's immediately you're gonna see the
person's name got you that's just that's
the that's the one that's one of the
positives of social media Griffin uh you
don't tour anywhere coming up uh later
what does this come on this summer this
will be 27. so oh
yeah nothing said I don't I don't know
what's going on at Late July
this is like 2024 no all right you're
gonna be around Jurassic Park nine is
coming out and uh do you have any movies
you're excited to see this summer but
like when the year started what was the
movie you're like Circle you're like
that's the one I Gotta See man there's
nothing really yeah
or Barbie Nothing movies have been so
disappointing like Oppenheimer why are
we making that
Hitler the young years is that one gonna
come out too we're making it it's like
because it's coming out the same weekend
as Barbie and it's a great it's a great
dichotomy of choice I just sometimes not
every story needs to be told but but
Barbie is you're fine with Barbie no I
just even Barbie like how they like are
they we'll find out how they're gonna
ruin Barbie
because our our idea of like because
there was so much controversy
surrounding Barbie in the like early
2000s late 90s you know what I mean of
this like uh the body body image and
like you know and then it was like
because I love that you have yeah I love
that but that's a new thing yeah you
know and even if they had like the
different color Barbies back in the day
nobody was talking about them there you
know what I mean they were like they
were in the closet you know I think
you're saying it I think you're seeing
it opening weekend I mean you will by
the time this podcast comes out yeah
well my my wife is probably gonna be
like
and then on the way there we're gonna be
I'm a Barbie girl you can have the Nicki
Minaj I spice version because they redid
it they did there you go I don't know if
you think they were gonna make a Barbie
movie and Nicki Minaj was not gonna get
involved in that come on now okay are
you just uh Eric Griffin on the socials
yeah just at Eric Griffin um yeah I love
I I love movies I I talk about movies
too on riffing with Griffin a lot you
know I'm going to be reviewing the flash
there you go which just probably way
past now since this is coming out I
think given your take on the turtles
people are going to want to tune in to
hear retroactively how you felt I really
do think and any other movie you see
you're always welcome on the show yeah
thank you so much for being here like
I'm interested to hear what you say
about this now and I'm not interested to
hear about what anybody says about
anything we're interested to hear from
our fans as well our fresh ketchup crew
you can email us RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com subscribe rate review
whatever your platform of choice asks
you to do do it for us here at Rotten
Tomatoes it's wrong and for riffing with
Griffin Eric Griffin thank you best and
one of the best Comics you will ever see
when he's in your town go see him
Jacqueline Coley we have a TBD on our
next movie and so we can make it up we
could just pick anything I'm gonna say
we're doing the secret of the nib and
Brian has to now can I tell you
something I know everything about that
movie I've never actually
and I'll just try my best to sear the
ship for the whole gang here at Rotten
Tomatoes I am Mark Ellison thank you so
long and cowabunga
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]